in the bronx getting ready to go yankees
and twins a makeup from their rain out
earlier
this summer in august and luis heal
towing the slab in the boogie down on a
monday afternoon to be his fifth start a
fastball well above average velocity
spin and life the slider really good too
and to me the last piece of the puzzle
for him is the confidence here's jorge
polanco most consistent hitter in the
twins lineup this season having a really
strong year
and polanco lifts one high and deep and
there goes number 30.
jorge polanco with his 30th of the year
and the twins strike first two to
nothing yeah congratulations to jorge
that's a franchise record right there
for switch hitters more than chile davis
more than roy smalley and now polanco
alone atop
that list with 30 home runs and now 88
knocked in
and that's the first home run allowed by
heel in his young big league career and
now five starts so two down and we'll
see if miguel cino can snap his over
he's hitless over his last 13 at bats
cino lifts one to left field and deep
gallow is back he's at the wall and
that's gone right on cue miguel indeed
snaps the offer with his 27th home run
and that was a first pitch fastball and
ceno just cleared the wall and left but
miguel adding on four-nothing twins all
here in this great first inning john
gantt made his first start as a twin
against these same yankees back in
august went three and a third and
gotta limit the walks obviously that's a
high number and he knows that
another one right there beating into the
ground
and
in time to get him good play by simmons
he
had to skid her to his left a long way
and then
kind of an awkward throw but he got
there this is a big exhale for yankees
fans david just seeing aaron judge in
the lineup today after he left last
night with dizziness
and judge works a two-hour walk and now
wait a minute let's see here
as rocco ball delhi and michael salazar
they're coming out to check on john
gantz his fastball we've seen hit 95 96
miles per hour
and i think he hit 91 once but they were
all sitting at 88 and 89. something
might be up with gant
physically so john gant
has to leave the game so now farrell
will try to pick up the game here here's
stanton judge at first two away
two hopper to donaldson and there's the
fourth play at second and that's the end
too fast to begin the third byron had
the ball hard but caught by gallow in
the first inning
now buxton lifts one to left and deep
gallows going back and that ball's gone
buxton connecting on the first pitch of
the third inning his 14th of the year
and it's five to nothing twins that was
a fastball in bucks and he just he's
swinging early look at the scouting
report on him he likes to swing early
in account and he got that fastball and
turned it around pretty good smiles all
around labor torres moving over to
second base not just for today but
perhaps for a longer period of time
jorge polanco polanco hit a two-run home
run his first time on one hop torres
gets to it
one down
yankee still looking for their first hit
on the day gallows struck out his first
down and he bunts great drag bunt that's
going to be a base hit
first hit of the game for the yankees
and a wise decision from joey gallo
see if the joey gallow drag bunt can
spark anything for the yankees
offensively first hit of the game for
the bombers here is voight
voight could erase it five four three
double play so a race
the bunt based hit by gallow that's a
five
four three
white doesn't run all that well easy
double play two now here's jeffers two
on two out
looped in the air to shallow center
gardner there
inning over
heels settles down after a tough
beginning so there's one away with
weighted third and that will bring up
le mayhew
the mayhew drives that to right field
kepler back at the wall leaping did he
grab it he did
what a catch from kepler
wade will trot home on the sacrifice fly
yankees on the board but an outstanding
play he catches every ball he should
have and then he makes some great plays
on top of it just like this he's
as solid as it comes i think in right
field we go to the bottom of the seventh
yankees are down five to one
they've been held to two hits by
a gaggle of minnesota pitchers and the
old two swag and a miss and down he goes
and a breaking ball so two fastballs and
a hook and stanton strikes out
so one down first strikeout for duffy
on a great knuckle curve here's joey
gallo as one of the two yankee hits i
think one out here in the seventh it
makes sense for him to hit it to the
moon
well he hit it to the moon
5-2 game
joey gallo with his 33rd home run of the
season and the yankees creep a little
closer
and how about joey gallo the yankees
have three hits two of them by gallow
one a drag bunt and the other uh
a gallow type home run
if the yankees are gonna turn this thing
around
and if they have another streak in them
that guy's gonna be right in the middle
of well rizzo pinch hitting and ahead
three-and-oh now
sanchez on deck to pinch it as the
yankees try and get something going here
in the eighth
and rizzo works a four-pitch walk the
lead-off man on
down 5-2
sanchez skies that down the left-field
line
ref schneider down to make the catch
for the first down
and if gardner gets on he is a tying run
the payoff
ball four gardner works the walk and
judge will come to the plate
as the tying run here in the eighth
another high curveball the duffy does
not get the call on
rocco ball delhi still upset about those
high curve balls that caught the top of
the zone but were called balls from
tyler duffy so baldelli's been tossed
the yankees hoping their offenses day is
just starting
crowd finally with something to cheer
about
first and second two out yankees down
three bottom of the eighth and judge up
against columbine
judge drives that in the air to deep
right that ball is gone
aaron judge
drops the gavel
a three-run game-tying homer
it's 5-5
aaron judge returning to mvp form this
year by staying healthy for the majority
of the season
and some juice and electricity in the
ballpark arise at second
buxton at first chapman against polanco
lifted in the air
to left center
gardner tracking under it there
over one down and here comes gary
sanchez pinch hit in the eighth inning
sanchez rips that to left field a base
hit torres rounding third that will do
it
a much needed
walk-off win in the bronx as sanchez
ends it and the yankees win it in
dramatic fashion
a 6'5 come from behind victory